-Performing her new song
"Puppy and a Truck,"
here's Jenny Lewis!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ My 40s are kicking my ass ♪
♪ And handing them to me
in a margarita glass ♪
♪ I was infatuated
with an older m-a-an ♪
♪ And then I dated
a psychopath ♪
♪♪
♪ So I'm 44 in 2020 and ♪
♪ Thank God
I saved up some money ♪
♪ Time to ruminate like,
what the heck was that? ♪
♪♪
♪ I don't mess with MOPAR,
Tesla, or Ford ♪
I'm a Chevrolet Angel, Lord♪
♪ Traded my '64 Malibu
for a van ♪
♪ And to tell you the truth ♪
♪ That's the only regret
I have ♪
♪ I need a dog
that's hypoallergenic ♪
♪ In the poodle milieu
and photogenic ♪
♪ Don't shed, don't bark,
and can play in the band ♪
♪♪
♪ I don't got no kids,
I don't got no kids ♪
♪ I don't got no roots ♪
♪ I'm an orphan,
catch me if you can ♪
♪ I'm lacing up my boots ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]